NOW OBVIOUSLY THESE TEXT
MESSAGES COMING OUT.
>> Sean: UNBELIEVABLE.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO FOLLOW
THIS STORY.
THANK YOU, ED HENRY.
ALSO BIG NEWS TONIGHT ON
URANIUM ONE.
WE ARE LEARNING THAT THE FBI
INFORMANT AT THE CENTER OF
THIS SCANDAL IN FACT TOLD
CONGRESSIONAL COMMITTEES
THAT RUSSIA PAID MILLIONS TO
THE U.S. LOBBYING FIRM APCO
WORLDWIDE IN A BID TO
INFLUENCE THEN SECRETARY OF
STATE HILLARY CLINTON BY
HELPING BILL CLINTON’S
CHARITIES.
IN A STATE OBTAINED BY FOX
NEWS, THE INFORMANT SAYS
THAT RUSSIAN NUCLEAR
OFFICIALS TOLD HIM AT
VARIOUS TIMES, QUOTE:  THEY
EXPECTED APCO TO APPLY A
PORTION OF THE $3 MILLION
ANNUAL LOBBYING FEE IT WAS
RECEIVING FROM THE RUSSIANS
TO PROVIDE IN-KIND SUPPORT
FOR THE CLINTON’S GLOBAL
ANYWHERE TIA AND APCO WAS
EXPECTED TO GIVE ASSISTANCE
FREE OF CHARGE TO THE
CLINTON GLOBAL INITIATIVE AS
PART OF THEIR EFFORT TO
CREATE A FAVORABLE
ENVIRONMENT TO ENSURE THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION MADE
AFFIRMATIVE DECISIONS ON
EVERYTHING FROM URANIUM ONE
TO THE U.S.-RUSSIAN CIVILIAN
NUCLEAR COOPERATION
AGREEMENT.
WE DID REACH OUT TO APCO FOR
COMMENT.
THEY TOLD US, IN PART, THE
ALLEGATIONS ARE FALSE AND
UNFOUNDED.
APCO ALSO TOLD US THAT ITS
VOLUNTEER WORK FOR THE
CLINTON GLOBAL INITIATIVE
AND ITS ENGAGEMENT WITH THE
RUSSIAN FIRM TENNEX ARE
ABSOLUTELY NOT CONNECT YOU
HAD.
LAST NIGHT A CLINTON
SPOKESMAN CALLED THE FBI
INFORMANT A CHARADE.
JOINING US NOW WITH REACTION
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN MATT
GAETZ FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
SARA CARTER AND WELCOME BACK
JOHN SOLOMON FROM THE HILL.
JOB, LET’S START WITH YOU.
>> GOOD EVENING.
>> Sean: GIVE YOU A CHANCE
TO LAY THIS OUT.
>> MOST INTERESTING THING IS
WE NOW HAVE A REALLY
COMPLETE TIME LINE OF WHAT
THE FBI KNEW WIN.
WE NOW KNOW BEFORE THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION MADE THE
FOLLOWING DECISIONS
RESTARTED THE U.S. NUCLEAR
COOPERATION AGREEMENT WITH
RUSSIA, APPROVED THE URANIUM
ONE DEAL AND THEN GAVE
CLEARANCE SO THAT MANY
UTILITIES IN THE UNITED
STATES COULD BUY RUSSIAN
URANIUM, THEY KNEW THE
FOLLOWING THINGS, AT LEAST
THROUGH THE FBI.
THEY KNEW THIS.
ONE, THAT RUSSIA WAS
ASSISTING IRAN AND THEIR
ILLICIT NUCLEAR PROGRAM.
TWO, THAT THE APCO, THE
LOBBYING FIRM.
AT LEAST THE RUSSIANS WERE
CLAIMING THEY WERE PAYING
MONEY TO THEM IN AN EFFORT
TO HELP HILLARY CLINTON.
THREE, THE VERY RUSSIAN ARM,
IN THE UNITED STATES
SEPTEMBER HERE TO BUILD THIS
URANIUM BUSINESS WAS ENGAGED
IN BRIBERY, KICK BACKS
RACKETEERING AND EXTORTION.
IF YOU HAVE ALL OF THAT
INFORMATION, IT DOLLS RAISE
A GREAT PUBLIC POLICY
QUESTION WHY DID THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, HILLARY
CLINTON STATE DEPARTMENT,
THE OTHER DEPARTMENTS, WHY
DID THEY APPROVE THESE
DEALS?
>> Sean: UNBELIEVABLE THERE
WAS NEVER ANY SENSE TO THAT
SARA, I SEE YOU SHAKING YOUR
HEAD.
BOTH YOU AND JOHN HAVE BEEN
AT THE FOREFRONT OF ALL OF
THIS.
YOU BOTH KNOW THE INFORMANT.
>> YES.
THESE ARE THOUSANDS OF
DOCUMENTS, SEAN, SAVED FROM
THE TIME HE WAS WORKING WITH
THE FBI AS AN UNDERCOVER
INFORMANT.
AND I STRESS AGAIN, HE SPENT
NEARLY 3 DECADES WORKING
WITH U.S. INTELLIGENCE
AGENCIES, THAT INCLUDES THE
FBI ON MANY ISSUES.
A NUMBER OF ISSUES.
I WANT TO GO BACK TO ONE
POINT.
IN APRIL OF 2010, IS WHEN HE
INFORMED THE FBI OF WHAT HE
FOUND OUT REGARDING RUSSIA
AND IRAN.
THEY WERE AIDING IRAN WITH
THEIR FABRICATED ASSEMBLIES
FOR THEIR NUCLEAR REACTORS
WITH CONSULTATION AND WITH
FUEL.
SO THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
ACTUALLY KNEW THAT THIS WAS
GOING ON.
THERE WAS DOCUMENTED PROOF.
THERE WERE RECORDINGS.
BUT, YET, IN OCTOBER OF
2010, THEY STILL WENT
THROUGH WITH THE DEAL.
THE CFIUS APPROVED THE DEAL
FOR THE SALE OF THE CANADIAN
FIRM URANIUM ONE WHICH HAD
20% OF OUR URANIUM MINING
ASSETS IN THE UNITED STATES.
IN WYOMING IN PARTICULAR.
SO WE HAVE TO ASK OURSELVES
THESE QUESTIONS.
AND SAY IF THERE IS AN
INVESTIGATION GOING TO BE
THOSE INVESTIGATORS AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO
LOOK AT THE MONEY TRAIL.
>> Sean: UNBELIEVABLE.
WE WILL LEARN MORE ABOUT
THAT.
BOTH YOU AND JOHN AGREE.
I SEE YOU SHAKING YOUR
HEADS.
CONGRESSMAN GATES, WE DON’T
HAVE ENOUGH URANIUM,
CONGRESSMAN.
THE IDEA THAT FBI DIRECTOR
AT THE TIME MUELLER KNEW
BECAUSE WE HAD THE INFORMANT
ABOUT BRIBERY, EXTORTION,
KICK BACKS, MONEY LAUNDERING
AND THIS IS NEARLY 18 MONTHS
BEFORE CIACCHELLAOUS SIGNS
OFF ON THE URANIUM ONE DEAL,
KNOWING VLADIMIR PUTIN
WANTED A FOOT HOLD -- FOOT
HOLD IN OUR INDUSTRY?
IT’S MIND NUMBING THAT THIS
COULD HAVE EVER HAPPENED?
INCIDENT INDICATES, SEAN YOU
WOULD HAVE TO HAVE IMPROPER
INFLUENCE TO END UP WITH
THESE FACTS.
REAL QUESTION WHETHER OR NOT
THERE IS GOING TO BE ANY
CONSEQUENCES.
CLINTONS ARE USED TO HAVING
A DIFFERENT STANDARD OF
JUSTICE APPLIED TO THEM THAN
APPLIED TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
THAT’S WHY I FILED
LEGISLATION WITH COUNTLESS
OTHER CONSERVATIVE
COLLEAGUES LIKE MARK MEADOWS
AND JIM JORDAN AND TODD
ROKITA CALLING FOR A SPECIAL
COUNSEL LOOKING INTO THE
CLINTON FOUNDATION IN
URANIUM ONE.
WE CAN’T HAVE MUELLER
INVESTIGATE HE SHOULD HAVE
RAISED AN OBJECTION.
WE’LL CAN’T HAVE ROSENSTEIN
INVESTIGATE BECAUSE WE HAVE
SEEN HOW HE IS TIED UP.
JEFF SESSIONS HAS RECUSED
HIMSELF.
THE ONLY WAY THIS DOESN’T
BECOME THE NEXT BENGHAZI
STIR UP A BUNCH OF FACTS BUT
LET THE CLINTONS OFF THE
HOOK IS APPOINT A SPECIAL
COUNSEL AND WE NEED OUR
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
>> Sean: YOU MEAN SEPARATE
AND APART FROM THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL INVESTIGATING THE
INVESTIGATORS.
WE HAVE SO MUCH TO GET TO
AND SO LITTLE TIME.
JOHN AND SARA IN PARTICULAR,
I WANTED TO ASK YOU, WILL WE
HEAR FROM THE INFORMANT YOU
BOTH KNOW?
JOHN?
>> THAT’S A GOOD QUESTION.
I MEAN, THIS INTERVIEW WAS A
NON-TRANSCRIBED INTERVIEW
WITH STAFF, NOT MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS.
AND I WOULD EXPECT THAT BOTH
STAFFS WILL MEET, DECIDE
WHAT HE TOLD THEM AND DECIDE
WHETHER THEY WANT TO HAVE A
PUBLIC HEARING.
I THINK THAT’S THE NEXT
STEP.
>> Sean: SARA, WILL WE HEAR
FROM HIM.
>> YES.
I BELIEVE WE WILL IT’S
STRITTLELY IMPORTANT.
THAT’S WITH HIS ATTORNEY
VICTORIA TOENSING.
SHE WILL, I THINK, MAKE IT
AFFORDABLE FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE TO SEE HIM.
>> Sean: UNBELIEVABLE WORK.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO PEEL